Peggy 18
all I really want is for everything to
go back the way that it was for that
night
so does the man are you gonna kill huh
[ __ ] I said though this city survived
war of 1812 the Civil War and God knows
how many hurricanes but when Lincoln
clay went after the mob he inflicted
more damage than all the wars and
hurricanes combined with a [ __ ] you
think you're going
Sall marcano deserve to die I won't
argue otherwise kill him but let that be
the end of it that's not enough enough
if you say is enough
this ain't about brittle bad or even
exact as street justice it's about
making that best to feel what it's like
to lose everything
welcome home son
watch as I take it all away from how do
I find out how we'll get ready to
[ __ ] kill no is just doing what I'm
told there's got to be something we can
do you are sad marcano we wouldn't be in
this [ __ ] mess if you've done what
you were supposed to do
it's the one way wrong once you start
down it ain't no turning back you are
who you are no point arguing with
yourself about